I was in a silly,
goofy mood this morning and decided that I wanted to go shopping.
I usually don't treat myself,
so lucky insisted I go. I didn't know exactly what I wanted,
but I knew I wanted to see their bags,
so they showed me a bunch of different options.
I usually stick with very classic colors,
but this matcha green was so beautiful.
There's just something about green bags
that are kind of intriguing to me going into fall.
This one was another classic.
Coming back to the green one,
I was so indecisive and couldn't make my mind up.
I kept going back and forth so long
that lucky fell asleep on the table,
which gave me even more time to try on clothing options.
I went with the yellow fur coat,
this brown bag, this wine red pouch for all of my chargers.
Also picked lucky up a little surprise that he didn't know about
since he was sleeping.
He's been using the same card holder for years now,
so I decided to get him a new little wallet.
While he was transferring his cards,
he showed me all the little notes that I wrote him that he keeps,
which made me so emotional.